it's time for the launching Khurana
scope a television journal of the
important issues of the hour brought
show you every Monday Wednesday and
Friday a presentation of the laun gene
which snore what's company maker of
launching the world's most honored watch
and wit nor distinguished companion to
the world honored lawn gene good evening
this is frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching kala scope mr. William
Bradford Huie editor of the american
mercury and mr. Henry Hazlitt
contributing editor of newsweek magazine
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the Honorable Joseph R McCarthy
United States Senator from Wisconsin the
opinions expressed are necessarily those
of the speakers Senator McCarthy our
viewers of course know that you are one
of the most controversial political
figures of our time and this is your
first appearance since your rather
overwhelming victory in the Wisconsin
primaries now sir what brings you East
at this time your program learns lumen
surgery and I believe that also this
week you expect to make an address and
Connecticut is that correct students one
line up the cloning Memorial Hall at
Bridgeport Connecticut and of course our
viewers know that in Connecticut that's
the home state of a man that you've had
a few words with senator bill Benton
announcer what what what's the purpose
of your going into into Connecticut is
it to defeat senator Brenda Benton or to
try to help defeat senator baton well
the purpose of mr. June will be
the same as the purpose in some 12 13
states now visit Metis to bring
important facts to the American people
you see I I got a very strong feeling
that the most of our people in public
life underestimate the intelligence the
American people and they try to argue
and tell people out of those I think you
need merely give the people of facts and
then you can go home and don't worry
they will try it and I Bridgeport
Connecticut do I understand you correct
let us say when you say that you are
opening a 12 or 13 state drive now and
supported the National ticket I think
I'll mean I may be wrong on the number
which is you a I think that I am now
scheduled to speak in some thirteen or
fourteen states where they have closed
senatorial contests well senator a lot
of people came into your state into
Wisconsin to try to defeat you in the
primaries and it seemed to have worked
the other way now don't you think that
perhaps when you go into these states it
may have that sort of effect Lutheran is
what that's from a lot right that's
right I'm sorry mr. Haslett
I do not intend to go to those dates and
tell the people out of those I don't
intend to go in and discuss the local
men running for Congress or Center I
intend to go to those states and give
the American people the cold documented
picture of the sellout in Korea the
extent to which communism has been
directing our foreign policy our
suicidal foreign policy if you please
and if the American people want more of
that then they can vote for the
president administration I may say this
that my appeal is is largely made to
Democrats
I feel the millions of Americans have
long water the Democrat ticket all right
just as loyal they love America just as
much they hate communism just as much as
the average Republican and I think it is
up to those loyal Democrats to realize
that as of today they don't have a party
in Washington
the only way they can have a change is
by voting Republican what do you think a
lot of Democrats came in and voted for
you and the Wisconsin election I don't
think it I know it our normal Hospital
is by two years ago the Democratic vote
was about 47 percent of the total
Republican vote 53 percent this year we
had a that see I think these figures are
at 83 percent Republican vote 17%
Democrat vote and most of the Democrats
apparently voted for McCarthy because I
carried the Democrat words normally
better than I carried the Republican
warrants which which proves my
contention that is that in this fight
against communism it isn't a Democrat
fight at his new Republican fight and
for that reason I don't for any state
can tell the people out of all what are
the broader interpretation of your own
victory in Wisconsin as you see it wild
say mister has the number one it was not
a vote for McCarthy it was a vote on an
issue an all-important issue the
American people recognize that the one
real issue and not the phony issue is
the issue of communism corruption all
tied up with the Korean War and World
War call it two and a half call it a
police action called watch ma it means
that the American people are sick way
down deep inside that what's been going
on and that it was I'd like to consider
a tribute to McCarthy but it was not it
was a vote upon an all-important issue
and I just hope that many of our good
friends realize that that is the issue
they do imply senator by saying that
they didn't go to McCarthy you imply
that you've become something of a symbol
now to a large group of Americans now
just what do you believe you symbolize
in the American political scene now I
don't quite like though you put that
question in the figure-eight
let's put it this way many people have
been waiting for someone to expose the
extent to which our suicidal foreign
policy has been dictated from the
Kremlin they've been waiting for someone
to really get up on fight corruption
though I'm in like Senator William
Zapata and I think my people in
Wisconsin were voting an approval of a
fight against communism corruption they
sellout of American interests and they
weren't voting but they weren't voting
for Joe McCarthy well I have I happen to
be the recipient of the vote and I
certainly appreciate it a great deal
would you say the other side of that
coin is that you were the recipient of
all the protest vote in Wisconsin I mean
that that they were voting for you in
order to protest against what what you
outline have been the failures of the
administration the point will be
experienced senator I wanted to ask you
about this word McCarthyism am i right
supposing that the first one who used
that word was owen lattimore in
testimony before the tidings committee
well a lot of more first use did let mr.
me correct myself I think it was first
used by Lattimore or by The Daily Worker
but the testimony now is the 40 top
communists met in New York and decided
how they would fight McCarthy and that
they then coined the phrase McCarthyism
now as to the date of that for that is
the day before a lot of more tests my
test áfiveá the day after I frankly
don't know but that's the origin as you
see it either the daily workers
publication of it or the Owen Lattimore
testimony but the first time it was used
or the the testimony by howard rushmore
the 40 communist myth and said we will
coin the phrase McCarthyism and use ass
I wanted to ask you here something about
the point that came up in the testimony
at the congressional testimony about the
Institute of Pacific relations this was
about a year ago
and it was a letter written by the
secretary of the IPR
to a mr. Barnett asking about a meeting
they were going to have at Mount
Tremblant and the people that they Auto
invite to that meeting and William
Lockwood says here in writing a
secretary of the IPR another possibility
we might consider is someone from Knox's
office or Stimson's
Co and hiss meaning Alger Hiss mentioned
Adlai Stephens one of Knox's special
assistants well that must mean Adlai
Stevenson because there he was one of
Knox's special assistants said and there
was no Stephens now why in your opinion
would hiss back in 1942 have recommended
Adlai Stevenson as a participant in that
meeting what qualifications did Adlai
Stevenson to have as let's say a Far
Eastern expert at that time all the
qualifications at Alger Hiss wounded in
the man I would say and keep in mind
that Cole the other man recommended
Alger Hiss has been named under oath
seven times as either a communist or an
espionage agent I said let let me say
this I'd rather not go there Stevenson's
record into great detail this time
because we have just completed a
complete and thorough research on Adlai
Stevenson
who is only yet well I am that and I
intend to give that picture on a
nationwide network and television I hope
also and after I give that picture of
Stevenson it doesn't a picture that I've
created as his own history it's Adlai
Stevenson's history of Adlai Stevenson
since the time he entered the
agricultural department in 1933 from
Alger Hiss some problem the rest
centered and after I give that history
of Stevenson if the American people want
him they can have him I don't think
don't worry well senator I gather from
what you say that it's fair to infer
that you will not avoid the
personalities in your thirteen states
that you expect to speak in
I will never avoid giving the facts to
the American people
mr. Huey it's so easy you see to talk
about communism generally to talk about
the sellout in China and Korea generally
but unless you call the role of the
traitor guess unless you call a roll of
those who have been responsible for the
suicidal foreign policy it's a waste of
the speaker's time on the audience time
and I don't intend to ever get up and in
general terms talk about treason talk
about sellouts
I you see foreign policy is Mike little
Topsy doesn't just grow treasonous Mike
little Topsy it doesn't just grow it's
created by men with faces and men with
names and I think those of us who've
been elected by the American people
demand the watchtower is unless we have
the intelligence to recognize the
traitors and then if I may use a word
which we use in Wisconsin as we have the
guts to name we should be taken down
from those watchtowers and should not be
representing the American people and I
don't intend to ever avoid giving the
names of traitors giving the names of
Communists when I discover them an
important position well senator we
appreciate it very much for being with
us tonight
well thank thank you much
the editorial board for this edition of
the long gene Khurana scope was mr.
William Bradford Huie
and mr. Henry Hazlitt our distinguished
guest was the Honorable Joseph R
McCarthy United States Senator from
Wisconsin it's World Series time again
the best state of the year for baseball
fans and this year again the World
Series is launched in time yes all
umpires oppose American and national
baseball leagues use nineteen marches
exclusively for timing all the games
including the World Series truly the
most honored watch in the world of sport
is launching the world's most honored
watch the only watch in history to win
10 world's fair grand prizes twenty
eight gold medals and so many honors for
accuracy in fields of precise timing now
that's why throughout the world no other
name on a watch carries the prestige of
launching the world's most honored watch
in sport the watch of first choice with
discriminating people the world over and
yet you know that you may buy and own or
buy and proudly give the long gene watch
for as little as seventy one fifty
launching the world's most honored watch
premiere product to the lawn gene but
nor wats company since eighteen sixty
six maker of watches of the highest
character
you
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time for the long gene Khurana scope a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour broadcast on behalf
of launching the world's most honored
watch and wit nor distinguished
companion to the world honoured Longy
this is frank night reminding you that
long jean and wit nor watches are sold
and serviced from coast to coast by more
than four thousand leading jewelers who
proudly displays this emblem agency for
lawn jean with nor watches
starts party night mr. mrs. north on the
CBS television network
it's time for the launching promise coke
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
monday wednesday and friday a
presentation of the laun gene which noir
watts company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching chrono scope mr. William
Bradford Huie editor of the american
mercury and mr. hardy birth noted
correspondent and author our
distinguished guest for this evening is
dr. Corliss Lamont American Labour Party
representative doc dr. Lamont our
viewers of course many of them know that
you are somewhat controversial political
figure and I'm sure they welcome you
tonight and will extend to you the same
degree of tolerance that they extended
to the views expressed here on their
last program by Senator McCarthy now
tonight sir I believe you are a
candidate for the United States Senate
in New York is that correct that is true
it's my first campaign for political
office and and and you are the candidate
for the American Labor Party in New York
that's true and as that party affiliated
with the Progressive Party nationally
yes are a national ticket for president
has Vincent Hallinan and for vice
presidential out of Bath's an American
Labor Party is the New York unit of that
party now that's the party that our
viewers remember was headed by mr.
Wallace in 1948 correct is that that's
yes sir now sir you are have been known
through most of your active lifetime I
believe as an American who was generally
friendly toward the Soviet Union is that
correct sir t would you so classify
yours I think you could say that
yes they asked a question here doctor
about the great issue in the world of
course today is whether we can have
peace with Russia we have spending
billions of dollars on the premise that
we have to slave operation attack and so
forth with sending troops abroad Europe
and all that now do you think it's
possible to make peace with Russia
without force of arms
I saintly do think it's possible and of
course if you resort to force of arms
that will result in a terrible third
world war which nobody can win I believe
that in spite of the Soviet Union's
mistakes which I think of many and in
spite of mistakes on the American side
we can get together over the conference
table and wake these things out making a
start with relaxing the tensions that
are existing in the world today just
what would be your method in doing that
getting together with a Stalin that's
what you would have to do well yes I
would approve of a perhaps a five power
conference or a two power conference on
a top level with Churchill Stalin Truman
whoever is President of the United
States and carrying out the idea that
the anti-communist nehru suggested
recently of talking these things over in
a v power conference around the
conference table now there have been
many such conferences as these and we've
usually been disillusioned why do you
think this time that it'll work out I
don't promise it will wake out but of
course I believe we should make
immediate steps toward relaxing these
tensions by getting an immediate
ceasefire in Korea and then perhaps
letting China into the United Nations
and then restoring oil trade which has
been disrupted over the past few years
how do we get a C's firm well I think
that the best plan that has been
suggested is to let the prisoner of war
issue at present go over for settlement
between four neutrals Switzerland Sweden
Poland and Czechoslovakia and let that
be settled after the ceasefire and truce
has been made on the present basis I
think the North Koreans and the Chinese
would agree to such a compromise and
that it could be worked out and say this
endless slaughter which is going on over
there in Korea well sir now in order to
catch your views properly sir is it true
to say we will mention that you were one
of them
consumers generally friendly toward
Soviet Union now you made several trips
to Russia didn't you during the 30s I
made two trips mr. Yuri in 1932 in 1938
and and during that that period you were
one of the Americans who thought that
there was something enormous ly hopeful
for mankind going on in Russia that's
right but I was never an apologist for
them I always saw the mistakes and the
evils in the Soviet Union it seems to me
that any country has both it it's good
and bad sides and that's certainly true
of Russia now for instance the Kurds
trials in 1937 I you were one of the
Americans who thought that those files
were properly and were honorable trials
and that the government the Soviet Union
was proper in carrying out that purge
well I think that innocent people
suffered in that page mr. Yuri but so
far as the great Moscow trials were
concerned I think that they were genuine
and I have a supporter in Winston
Churchill who in one of his books has
said that he believed they were
necessary they'll regret aful now you
have also is it fair to say that that
you've been generally critical of
organized religion and the Christian
religion particularly well I've been
critical of theology and political ideas
in the churches mr. Healy
but naturally I support the New
Testament ideals and teachings of Jesus
and in my own philosophy bring those in
constantly you get it's been your belief
that the Christian Church in Western
Europe for instance has been a a
reactionary political as well I would
always want to be specific on that and
say what change and exactly what was
their policy because many churchmen many
Catholics to have taken a liberal policy
and Social Affairs and are fighting for
international peace today I'm unwilling
to make any overall condemnation of a
church or religion or a country now you
have also been a mem
an officer of a number of organizations
that have been labeled subversive by the
government the United States now sir do
you have any any regrets as to those
memberships well I can't think that I do
mr. Huey as a matter of fact the whole
subversive listing it seems to me was
unconstitutional and illegal and it was
carried out as you know without giving
any of these organizations a chance to
testify and answer the charge and
against them well sir now with that with
that background what do you regard is a
candidate for the United States Senate
what do you regard as the most important
issue before the American people today
well I think there are two most
important issues if I may put it that
way the restoration of civil liberties
for everybody in this country capitalist
wakers socialists communists the enemies
of Communists Catholics and atheists and
everything else and the second big issue
is international peace and disarmament
now those two issues I am emphasizing in
my campaign and of course they are tied
up together well now on the first issue
the restoration of civil liberties I
take it by that you mean that civil
civil liberties are threatened today
that they need restoring Oh more than
threatened they have been suppressed
right and left here and indeed it is
borne over from the field of
governmental violation the two non
governmental violation in private
entertainment fields like radio even
television movies and publishing which
would you say that Senator McCarthy is a
is a part of that threat I'm afraid he
is because McCarthy has kept the
American people stirred up over an
alleged threat of communist insurrection
here and it seems to me has gone much
too far in the direction of suppressing
actually the Bill of Rights and making
everybody scared to death so that people
now adopt what they call self-censorship
in order to not go out on a limb and not
stick their necks out they just keep
quiet well it's a making everybody
scared to death do you believe that a
very large number of a mirror
are living in fear today of Senator
McCarthy and what he stands for well not
so much of McCarthy himself as the the
fear that he has stirred up the fear of
government people losing their jobs
because they're accused of some vague
relationship to a communist organization
back in 1932 all this I consider going
pretty far astray but it's not only
McCarthy the Democrats have a man like
that and his name is McCarran and he is
just as bad in my opinion and more
powerful actually in the Senate of the
United States
well sonar on this problem of peace
which I believe that both major parties
have found to be the issue that more
people are interested in now and in
Western Europe you've expressed in it
your opinion on career in Western Europe
are you critical of our maintaining
troops in Western Europe well I I am
indeed I think that it's unnecessary I
don't think that there is really a
danger of Soviet military aggression in
Western Europe because that isn't the
way the Soviets wait they wait through
propaganda and taking advantage of bad
economic conditions now as it happens we
are bringing about bad economic
conditions in Western Europe that's one
of the great troubles with our policies
doctor let me interrupt right here to
ask this question because it is
pertinent suppose we withdrew all
financial aid and all of our troops from
Europe do you think that the Communists
but pretty much leave Europe alone do
you think Europe is the European
countries themselves would go communist
internally not necessarily I believe
myself and hope about the European
countries of England France and Italy
might establish reformed government
labeled governments such as you have in
England today but they would have no
allegiance to Russia
not necessarily there would still be
strong communist movements in those
countries but what America has done it
seems to me through foisting this
armaments program on them and disrupting
east/west prey is to depress their
living standards and in that way open
the gates to the communist parties more
than before because communists as you
know thrive on economic misery and on
bad economic condition doctor as a final
question
would you tell our audience what kind of
America you would like to see during the
next four years well I believe America
is a great country with a great
tradition but that tradition has been
betrayed since the death of Franklin D
Roosevelt I believe that with the
re-establishment of peace we can
re-establish civil liberties here and
then start a March renewal March in
America toward economic security and
abundance for everyone in this country
is it fair to say that you are a
socialist and that you want to see peace
restored and then you want to see this
government proceed further in the
direction of socialism
that's right toward plan socialism with
Democratic means putting it into effect
and not revolution you think private
property should be on by the state
well not all private property mr. right
but the main means of production and
distribution yes well sir I'm certain
that our viewers have enjoyed these
forthright views from you sir and thank
you very much for being with us the
opinions expressed this evening are
necessarily those of the speakers the
editorial board for this edition of the
launching Cronos cope was mr. William
Bradford Huie
and mr. Hardy Burt our distinguished
guest was dr. Corliss Lamont American
Labour Party representative
it's World Series time again the best
days of the year for baseball fans and
this year again the World Series is
launched in time yes all on Parsa both
American and national baseball leagues
use on team watches exclusively for
timing all the games including the World
Series truly the most honored watch in
sports is launching the world's most
honored watch the only watch in history
to win 10 world's fair grand prizes
twenty eight gold medals and so many
honors for accuracy in fields of precise
timing now that's why throughout the
world no other name on a watch carries
the prestige of launching the world's
most honored watch in sport the watch of
first choice with discriminating people
the world over and yet do you know that
you may buy and own or buy and proudly
give the long gene watch for as little
as seventy one fifty launching the
world's most honored watch premiere
product to the lawn gene with nor wats
company since eighteen sixty six maker
of watches of the highest character
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at this
same time for the long gene Chronos code
a television journal of the important
issues of the our broadcast on behalf of
launching the world's most honored watch
and wit nor distinguished companion to
the world honored launching this is
frank night reminding you that launching
and wit nor watches are sold and service
from coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
display this emblem agency for launching
with nor watch
it's time we picked the winner on the
CBS television network
it's time for the launching promise coke
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour a presentation of the
laun gene which snore what's company
maker of launching the world's most
honored watch and wit nor distinguished
companion to the world honored lawn gene
good evening this is frank night may I
introduce our co-editors for this
edition of the launching chrono scope
mr. William Bradford Huie editor of the
american mercury and mr. Elliott Ames
associate editor of United Nations World
our distinguished guests for this
evening is the honorable fuller warren
governor of the state of florida
governor worn out viewers of course know
you as one of the more controversial
political figures in the south they
remember a little engagement that you
had with senator Kefauver during his
investigation and tonight i'm sure that
our viewers would like some of your
expressions as to the political
situation in Florida now first sir we've
had governor Talmadge on this program a
few days ago and he told us his position
we've had certain other southern
governors what's your position in the
present national campaigns mr. Hugh I am
100 percent plus for Stevenson and
Sparkman well now are you one of the
radical governors in the south or are
you conservative where do you shed in
this political firmament mr. Hugh I
think you might appropriately and aptly
describe me as a liberal conservative
governor does a live liberal
conservative believe in the FPPC
not a compote rafi PC mr. Hains we
believe in the Constitution that I
believe all good Americans doing as we
read the Constitution it doesn't give
the federal government the power to pass
on FPPC that could be enforced with jail
sentences your athletes greater than
well I don't know so much about that I'm
an American first but I believe in
treating everybody fair and right and
giving everybody an equal opportunity to
a job well now I do mr. Stevenson's
positions on those issues
altogether suits you sir well uh they
come narrow suit me than most positions
on that subject do including their
general Eisenhower's well I can tell
just what his position is he vacillate
so and changes from day to day so that I
can't keep up with it when it was late
its position mr. Haines well now general
eisenhower paid a widely publicized
visit to your state recently what was
the effect of his trip there uh well
it's hard to say mr. Healey I've been in
politics for 25 years and about all that
I've learned to do is to make a wild
guess so I don't pose as an expert even
a semi equation might be a pseudo expert
but he was well received there great
many people turned out to see him and he
was treated with that famous Florida
hospitality and cordiality the feeling
years that he got more hospitality than
he'll get votes down there you think
that also applies to the effect that
Jimmy Byrnes might have and you switched
to Eisenhower well governor Burns is one
of the most beloved and revered figures
in the south and we have real affection
for him in the south but I doubt if any
political leaders position in the south
will greatly influence and votes of a
great number of people in the south just
about everybody in the south is I
suspect most I'm on the north and west
do their own voting their independence
when it comes to casting a vote you have
a lot of Republicans in Florida don't
you governor yes sir we've had a very
large Republican infiltration into
Florida in recent years and I may say
we've welcomed them because nearly all
of them are solvent and well
and capable of doing a whole lot to
develop our state they make fine
citizens but very you might say
unsatisfactory voters well sir now about
Florida and has the industrialization
proceeded as fast in Florida as it has
in other states very very fast mister
Huey for many years we belong on tourism
and agriculture but short on
industrialization but under the
beneficent policies of Roosevelt we have
proceeded rapidly in the
industrialization of Florida our
industry is fast moving up alongside our
agriculture and our tourism what about
tourism how important is tourism to the
economy of Florida mr. Huey it is almost
all important the people of Florida have
a total annual income of about three and
a half billion dollars about 1 billion
of those three and a half billion
dollars is derived from tourism so you
can see that about one out of every
three and a half dollars we take in
comes from these splendid fine affluent
people from other states who come to
Florida for rest relaxation and
reinvigoration and conservation they
also come for divorces don't they
governor well if you haven't come down
for marital liberation but of course but
how do is one of them any you might say
facets of Florida's charm well is
Florida able to compete with such states
as Arkansas and Nevada and divorces mr.
Huey we are little bit handicapped they
have a I believe a sixth day a sixteen I
mean six weeks residence requirement in
those two states and you have to live in
Florida for the full period of 90 days
before you can file a divorce suit that
means you make more money from each
divorce first thing yes longer we keep
them there the more they spend there of
course but I believe it's money well
spent because they get a new lease on
life and recapture a whole lot of lost
youth while they are down land and just
everywhere
benefitted improve its the nearest thing
to go into paradise that can be achieved
without dying McLean is gambling
included in that in that governor no so
we have suppressed gambling in Florida
almost completely for more than 50 years
it it operated just about as openly
there as filling stations but in the
last three or four years we have just
about suppressed illegal gambling we
have on gambling a paramutual gambling
at the horse tracks and old traction at
Highline but in Florida now you run a
serious risk if you get in a dice game a
card game whether there's any money on
you will say that the senator Kefauver
was responsible for that change vision
he came down there and did a lot of
shouting and hollering and screaming and
battering about it after we had made a
good start towards suppressing it he is
was using a special Senate committee for
the purpose of promoting himself for
president and he just came down got a
lot of headlines and did a lot of tubs
up in and noise-making down there mr.
Hains well I was it was senator Kefauver
I believe charge that some of those
people around Miami were good friends of
yours who were involved in that gambling
mr. Huey a man who run for office is a
good friend everybody let him be a good
friend to him the fact he is an under my
administration illegal gambling in
Florida has been suppressed for the
first time in more than 50 years it was
introduced into Florida in the eighties
as I recall it and it had run almost
without molestation of all that time
under my administration we have
practically suppressed illegal gambling
we have plenty of legal pari-mutuel
governor I wonder why that side of the
question
didn't appear more plainly in the
newspapers around the country
well senator Kefauver and his
accomplices were seeing that it didn't
they were bringing out what evidence
they wanted to bring out and suppress
and what evidence they didn't want to
he was running for president he was not
making a bona fide II investigation mr.
Haines now sir since the tourism to come
back to that subject since tourists
contribute about one-third of the total
income of Florida is one of your
pleasures and duties perhaps to invite
people there have you been on a tour for
instance yes sir I've just covered ten
of the finest of the 48 states with the
sole exception of Florida which of
course stands at the top of the list by
any standard or measurement but I just
come back from a tour of those 10 states
inviting everybody in those states who
hasn't already been to Florida to come
and those who have already been there to
come back and I should at this time like
to invite every person who is honoring
us by less than the end of looking in on
this program and I understand it's one
of the most popular programs in the
Western world
I should like invite everyone of them to
come to Florida we have about five
million annual visitors to Florida but
we've got room for plenty more down
there
governor just how many days in the year
does the Sun Shine employer
well it's schedule is 365 days it misses
the schedule once in a while mr. Haines
but in st. Petersburg as you know a
publisher gave away his pay for every
day in the year that the Sun didn't
shine a little bit some of the day he's
still in business he's still in business
and going strong yes sir just nobody's
in good a shape is lalangue gene watches
well governor to come back to
national political scene which I viewers
are particularly interested just how do
you believe that the election will go on
November the 4th 1952 mr. Hewett you
flatter me by asking me for what appears
to be an opinion of mine you appear to
be asking me if an opinion of mine as I
have said I've been in the politics on
the mostly on the outer fringes of it
for about 25 years more than half of my
lifetime and all I can do is make a
guest and they're usually wild guesses
but I'll make a wild guess and say in
answer to your question that the
Republicans in 1952 ad will be defeated
worse than they've been since 1936 ad
remember the carrot two states and you
think Florida will be in the Democratic
column yes sir I do and I'd like to give
you mr. hands a few of my reasons for
believing that in Florida we have
approximately 1 million 118 thousand
registered Democrats for the Big D I
mean and we have about 88,000
Republicans and about 5,000 independence
I don't believe that the most credulous
and naive man can believe that there'll
be enough desertions among those 1
million 118,000 democrats to give the
republicans of victory we got a little
taste of republicanism in 1928 we never
have recovered from it in Florida mr.
Haines we got another little taste of it
in 1950 when one of our counties
Pinellas County went Republican and the
people are still weeping over it almost
and we just can't take the panics it
seems to go with republicanism we don't
like hard time we love prosperity down
and we've got it under the Democrat
governor I'm sure that out here
very much appreciated seeing you tonight
and thank you for being with us sir
Thank You mr. Yuri the opinions
expressed are necessarily those of the
speakers the editorial board for this
edition of the launching Cronus cope was
mr. William Bradford Huie and mr.
Elliott Ames our distinguished guests
was the honorable fuller Warren governor
of the state of Florida
it's World Series time again the best
days of the year for baseball fans and
this year again the World Series is
launching time yes all the umpires -
both American and national baseball
leagues use launching watches
exclusively for timing all the games
including the World Series truly the
most honored watch in the world of sport
is long gene the world's most honored
watch the only watch in history ever to
win 10 world's fair grand prizes twenty
eight gold medals and so many honors for
accuracy in fields of precise timing
that is why throughout the world no
other name on a watch carries the
prestige of launching the world's most
honored watch in sport the watch of
first choice with discriminating people
the world over and yet do you know that
you may buy and own or proudly give a
long gene watch for as little as seventy
one fifty launching the world's most
honored watch premiere product of the
lawn gene with nor wats company since
eighteen sixty six maker of watches of
the highest character
you
we invite you to join us for the launch
in chrono stroke a television journal of
the important issues of the are
broadcast on behalf of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored launching this is frank night
reminding you that long jean and wit nor
watches are sold and serviced from coast
to coast by more than four thousand
leading jewelers who proudly display
this emblem agency for launching with
Norma
enjoy the Jackie Gleason show on the CBS
television network
it's time for the launching Chronicle a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which noir
watts company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching chrono scope mr. William
Bradford Huie editor of the american
mercury and mr. Henry Hazlitt
contributing editor of newsweek magazine
our distinguished guest for this evening
is mr. t lamar Caudill former Assistant
United States Attorney General well
mister chloral now that you are back in
private life and done with being a
bureaucrat perhaps you can tell us
something about the pressures that were
brought on you when you were assistant
attorney general what kind of pressures
are they well mr. hazard the pressures
well I would say in the third dimension
if you can understand that but they came
largely from the Senators the
congressmen almost continuously from the
prominent men in public life that were
overall the hill they come in the form
of telephone calls or visits a lot well
the the greater number of communications
of course were over the telephone but
but there were many many conferences
that were had with senators and
congressmen in my office and if the
sudden they happen to be a little older
it's so busy I would accommodate the
German go to his office what would be a
typical request a typical request well
with tax cases for example be involved
oh yes when I was in the tax division
tax case would be involved
one who's troubled me a great deal
almost one of the very beloved uh when
the most beloved men in America I should
had you love him and I have caught him
so many times that was the
vice-president when they called me about
an old friend of his down in Louisville
more in a favor primary sir one sir he
was he was uh he was concerned about the
the illness of this fella and I told him
at everybody who came to see me about
tax cases were sick of something they
were sick something some was wrong with
him and I told him that the doctors and
the government doctors felt that that
the ordeal of a trial were not result in
the gentleman's death in the there was
no other alternative but to go ahead
with your in Pleasant do do now I must
Carter to identify you a little further
for our viewers of course your this man
from your from North Carolina happily
yes so full of joy and then for about
four years you were in the tax division
of the Department of Justice that's
right you had the say the authority the
prosecutor a tax case or else to settle
it
yes so even that that's what brought you
on all these pressures that's right
unfortunately you can't delegate this
power to another unless in your absence
and you really have to stand there and
all this committees got at you and then
the President himself hold off and fired
you didn't he yes sir he went blue blue
so me you see I thought that to
Manhattan had a reputation and sticking
fire everybody all his good friends you
were one of his good friends I sure
thought so I tell you book the legend
bill when he will he young will he will
he luck me out what makes what your
theory as to why the president sing it
to you at and gave you the boot such
fashion well I it would take too long to
go into my theory that our viewers of
course know you and one of these make
man your wife at least got a got out of
West was make coat did well she got out
of one that was paid for I was one thing
and she paid for it I have to the last
part though okay
rather than man code have anything to do
with it I don't much believe it I don't
believe it did mrs. Truman has a meat
cooking and I reckon a mother who has
long one for solo one who went for so
long and and she argued that she will
last for ten years just renovate to be
renovated just once a year that it was
all right I told her was suddenly
getting me in the Tony she bought it
what specifically were you charged with
whenever you were fired well outside
activities I've been trying to find out
mr. who here what the outside activities
world is that just me doing favors for
your friends I I don't know it's one of
those things that the President did not
tell the Attorney General mr. McGrath I
tried to find out I've been trying to
find out what these outside activities
well well mr. Coronel you already don't
know at the end of one of the committee
hearings the chairman of a subcommittee
a congressman King a year ago asserted
you'd been recreant to your trust and
the done irreparable damage to the
government now what is your comment on
that state yeah he said he said I had I
had done a disservice to my government
and I say to you Mr hazard when when
Chairman Cecil King made that remark he
he did a disservice to his government
and he did a disservice to the
Honourable people that tax division how
many I didn't like it Stephen either I
mean it taxed millions ooh but in the
four years you were you were in this tax
position sir how many cases would you
estimates you have approximate sixteen
thousand civil cases probably 45% were
compromising settled an approximate 2500
income tax fraud cases I say now these
cases you I'd like you to tell our
viewers you get calls from members of
Congress during this period very often
didn't you oh yes sir and those members
of Congress they wanted you to favorably
consider their constituents I assume yes
so they had as a part of the system is
oh yes they were they were they were
strong representation had been made
these gentlemen they were honorable in
all of their relations with me they were
some were very much convinced that I was
about to do an injustice by indict in
someone and of course I will try to
convince the congressman that I had no
other alternative because the fact was
so strong that it just had to be done
I'd like to take up one specific case
let's take the case of the Kansas City
vote frauds now you were in on that for
a while that's why you called in by
anybody or did you step in by yourself
most of the Kansas City investigation
stemmed from a good many calls that we
received in the way of complaints from
individuals out in the congressional
district that congressman Axtell and the
congressman slaughter this was a 1946
year so that was when I was on Axtell
was the congressman that the Democratic
candidate the President Truman favored
yes and it was it was argued that fraud
was used to elect him over his
Democratic opponent or the case yes so
that was a case of pride and a lot of to
do was done about it in Kansas City or
and then it came to your attention is
that well that's right yeah that's right
answer just by way of information how
does a man who's been District Attorney
down in North Carolina how does he get
the position such as you occupied in
Washington some senator bring you there
no so no senator had anything to do with
my going to Washington mr. Clark told me
that when I took over the office as
United States Attorney it had the lowest
rating in the United States and when and
when he wanted one to fill the vacancy
that he had created by exception the the
attorney generalship of the country he
said that because of the splendid record
which I had made he had talked with the
president and they had decided to extend
the invitation to me and that was why I
came to Washington
neither senator hood who was under too
then
Arsen - Bailey I believe so - Bailey are
neither one of the gentlemen knew about
the invitation to come and of course
they told me he went to see them
personally and after you get into such a
position where you have the decision
over many dollars millions of dollars in
tax cases all of these calls that you
get from the White House from members of
Congress that's inherent in our system
isn't it yes sir it's it is a very very
normal thing that one who has who has to
make the decision he has to face it
that's assaulted dr. Cottle I'd like to
get back to this specific case that we
took up because I think with the clarify
the whole situation if we went into
something like let's say the Kansas City
throat case now you were called in on
that and you stayed in for a while and
then you were taken off it well right no
what happened mr. hazard was that the
preliminary investigation this
preliminary investigation had become
quite a famous memoranda memorandum the
FBI had completed its preliminary
investigation in vain and brinson all
the Kansas City boys yes sir the Kansas
City kid embracing the investigation of
the Kansas City Star yes they had a
fifty investigators and there were 8,000
people interviewed and out of that
number 1354 affidavits were taken and
that was a part of the preliminary
investigation that were reported to me
by the FBI of course we analyzed these
things you turned it over to the FBI
well we asked them to investigate and he
asked them to - to make a preliminary
investigation so to determine because we
knew if we had a full investigation it
would cost a staggering sum of money
because it cost almost 3,000 and the
president called you off that
investigation or know through his orders
that you were called on oh no no no no
sir I was iris-t I never received any
communication from the White House from
any source and we all really believed
that the facts were not sufficient to
warrant a father
investigation because we could not find
well that was any evidence that two or
more people conspired together to
deprive someone of a right well old mr.
Carter
one of the important things to you I
believe is that when the last two or
three weeks you've undergone extensive
investigation in Washington by the shelf
committee after which mr. shelf more or
less rendered this judgment in which he
said that you were a quote an honest man
who was indiscreet in his associations
and a client conformer to the peculiar
moral climate of Washington are now is
that a fair description of your
experience Esser well I know that the
Chairman and mr. Keating was right when
they said to the American people that I
was an honest man
I have no disagreement there at all and
I know they're right they spoke of the
peculiar moral climate of Washington
secure it it is the most peculiar I
think they were right there it was most
kids most peculiar moral climate you'll
find any city in the world everybody who
gets off at Union Station off a bus or
when he parks his car comes in from the
National Airport he goes to Washington
for something and he disappointed if he
does not take it home with you I say
well I'm sure that our viewers very much
appreciated these frank statements from
you tonight sir and thank you for being
with us the opinions that you've heard
our speakers expressed tonight are
entirely their own the editorial board
for this edition of the launching Crona
scope was mr. William Bradford Huie and
mr. Henry Hazlitt our distinguished
guest was mr. t Lamar Cottle former
Assistant United States Attorney General
a watchmaker such as lon Jean recalls
that Christopher Columbus made his great
voyages before the watch was invented
his only timepiece an hourglass like
this 15th century one which happens to
be the property of the Hayden
Planetarium this of course had to be
reversed every half hour now Columbus
Day marks a milestone for launching
watches too because this gold medal was
presented to lon Jean at the San Luis
Columbian exhibition which honored the
400th anniversary of Columbus's
discovery of America now consider how
consistently long gene watches have
maintained their leadership over the
years long Jean is the only watch in
history to win 10 world's fair grand
prizes twenty eight gold medals and
literally thousands of awards for
accuracy from great government
observatories today's lon Jean watches
are our finest distinguished for
exclusive styling endowed with those
traditional qualities of accuracy and
long life for which launching watches
our world on it truly throughout the
world no other name on a watch means so
much as launching the world's most
honored watch premiere product of the
laun jean wit nor watch company since
eighteen sixty six maker of watches of
the highest character we invite you to
join us every monday wednesday and
friday evening at the same time for the
long gene chrono scope a television
journal of the important issues of the
hour broadcast on behalf of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
on a long chain
this is frank night reminding you that
on election day you're the most
important person in the country so
exercise your privilege as an American
citizen and vote for the candidate of
your choice
on earth wah-wah-wah is long gone gene
watches have won 10 world's fair grand
prizes twenty eight gold medals and more
honors for accuracy than any other time
T's launching the world's most honored
watch is made and guaranteed by the laun
gene with nor watch company it's time
for the launching promise Co a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought show you
every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which nor
what's company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the long
gene chroma scope mr. Donald I Rogers of
the New York Herald Tribune and mr.
William Bradford Huie editor of the
american mercury our distinguished
guests for this evening is the honorable
Owen Brewster United States senator from
Maine the opinions expressed are
necessarily those of the speakers
senator Brewster audience of course no
issues the distinguished Senate senior
senator from Maine how long have you
been in the Senate sir this is my 11th
year and what are your committee
assignments now sir I'm on Foreign
Relations and interstate and farm
commerce and I believe that our audience
understands that you are one of the
three senators who has just rejected the
nomination of dr. Jessup that's correct
isn't it sir yes there was a
subcommittee of five members and we've
held hearings for three weeks and three
of us voted against his confirmation
senator Smith senator Gillette on the
ground that he lacked popular confidence
I voted against him on the ground he
couldn't make himself understood
that was the first qualification of a
diplomat a senator I believe that mr.
Jessup's
background came into the discussion yes
eyes or police with Red China yes that
was the basis of the original attack
upon him and on the policies that he had
advocated president Stassen of the
University of Pennsylvania made some
very serious charges and substantiated
them pretty well with some of his
evidence how do you feel that this might
set a dangerous precedent in which the
past utterances of past beliefs of every
nominee would be scrutinized brought
forth to impugn him today my basis of
criticism was his lack of candor in
admitting the opinions he had held his
attempt to cover up of opinions which he
obviously had held we had four men's
into Smith and mr. Stassen
general Fortier and today Admiral cook
all testify they understood from Jessup
that he rather inclined to the
recognition of Red China he absolutely
denies it it doesn't seem all those men
could be wrong or else he doesn't have
the capacity to make himself understood
and that's unfortunate in the Dumon
you'd feel differently about him if he
had said well yes i did feel that way
about i think he would have made a much
better Shore and we had to bias down
there one of the delegates and he was
connected with various communist
organization he admitted it frankly said
he didn't realize at the time he was
sorry for you very much' boat and we
unanimously confirmed him today along
with eight other delegates and left to
Jessup out the Senate acted today to my
very great gratification I was glad they
took mrs. Roosevelt and Warren Austen
out of the class of those whom the
senator refused to confirm senator I
suppose that you are quite popular with
your colleague Senator McCarthy now as a
result of this action do you regard your
vote as
vindication of what is commonly known as
McCarthyism now I think the McCarthy
charges did not occupy as common at a
place in this situation as the Friends
of mr. Jessop food of desire they
started out to make McCarthy the issue
rather than Jessup but as a result of
the entry of Harold Stassen the issue
became Jessup and his actions this does
to a measurable extent vindicate
McCarthy's original charge a year ago
that he felt that Jessup was the
architect of a Far Eastern policy that
Senator Smith himself agreed was one of
the fundamental issues that was the
original McCarthy charge now the Senate
air on that issue I believe that you are
a well-known supporter of Senator Gaetz
candidacy for the presidency yes I have
long believed that he was the logical
nominee you've known the senator for
many years I believe yes I voted for him
for president the Harvard Law Review 30
years ago do you think that Senator Taft
number one can win the Republican
nomination I believe that he has the
most excellent chance I think he's a
long ways toward it today from what I've
observed in the country and do you think
that as the Republican nominee he will
have a good chance to defeat President
Truman's I think he'll make the kind of
a campaign which I believe the
Republicans in a many Americans want a a
fighting campaign that's the kind of a
man he is and he has a tremendous
knowledge of events that's one of his
unique qualifications because he has an
encyclopedic mind has it all his
fingertips and what do you think there
will be the principal issue in the
presidential campaign I think that
confusion corruption and communism are
altogether likely to be the major issues
in the campaign and I think we have a
great deal of ammunition on all those
cause confusion corruption and communism
that you you expect that to be one of
the Republican slogans I I it's my
slogan of interactive campaign seems
easy sorry
our medical agents is a frequent I'll
you were one of the many who went over
to see General Eisenhower this past
summer Sara's old and I assume that
after visiting General Eisenhower you
compared the General Eisenhower and mr.
Taft and came up with mr. Taft
no I wouldn't say that that was the case
I came back fully persuaded as I stated
that General Eisenhower was the
indispensable man in Europe and I was
very much gratified although you might
not agree to find the New York Times
agreed with me the other day when this
correspondent over in Europe had a
two-column story to the same effect
was that is very objective politicians
are sometimes suspect senator I'm sure
that our audience would like you to
discuss Spain because you've been active
and trying to obtain more American aid
for Spain I believe you also traveled
there yes you I've been over there
several times and feel very strongly
about the wisdom of our cultivating far
more closer relations with them now what
is the basis of that sir I mean are you
interested in cultivating them for
military reasons yes that is the
cornerstone I think all of our defense
authorities that's one thing on we have
which we have complete unification the
army because of the ground that is
offered the Air Corps because of the
splendid conditions you can operate all
the year and they are very good at
fields and the Navy because of the ports
and because it's the key to the
Mediterranean how we can ever expect to
have a great fleet over there in the
Mediterranean as we do now without
assured sympathetic cooperation from
Spain is incalculable how then do we
have all this opposition opposition from
the White House I think it is emotional
and
ideological the French and the British
governments now in power have been very
critical of the Franco regime and there
are many elements in this country who
agree if the British election should go
to mr. Churchill there would be quite a
change in the British attitude ah
Churchill who was all through the war
knows thoroughly that Spanish pictures
and I've discussed it with him this
summer and I know that he fully agrees
with those in this country who consider
Spain as the cornerstone twerpy in
defense quite parenthetically not to
leave Spain do you think Churchill has a
pretty good chance but that was the
feeling when I was there and apparently
averages the development since has
indicated it the betting odds are very
much in his favor as they were in favor
of mr. Dewey a couple of years ago
well senator I'd like to come back just
a moment to the military aspects of
Spain do our military authorities
believe that we could hold Spain in the
event of a war with Russia tyrannies are
the best natural barrier in the world
probably if you've flown over you'll see
it running from the Mediterranean to the
Atlantic and almost impenetrable barrier
so that it would be very feasible and
Spain has from 1 to 2 million men who
are good fighters whatever you think
about the Spaniards are certainly
fighters as they demonstrated in their
own civil war they've had a lot of
practice that's right and the opposition
we were speaking of the Opposition in
our country to our aid to Spain and you
said that it was emotional as the
religious issue also been important
there well that was what I referred to I
thought it's better to call it emotion
rather than a religious fanaticism but
that has been very greatly trade up and
agitated and I think it has been an
influence operating very powerfully in
our State Department as Manifest in
variety of ways now they finally
announced a year ago January
to normalize relations then this year
admiral Sherman had finally persuaded
them that we must cultivate closer
military arrangements and he was over
there I was there at the same time when
his tragic death came why is it that we
haven't heard anything more about it
since that was because the State
Department is now doing exactly what
they did on China and exactly what
they've done in some of the quarters
they are carrying on a slowdown on that
situation and are planning to sabotage
the program if they can and I think it
is a tragic blow at the adequate
preparations of our defense we sabotage
the money you've appropriated this
hundred we appropriated a year ago
sixty-two million dollars it took them
nearly a year to distribute it meanwhile
they gave 50 million dollars to
Yugoslavia before they even had any
authorization that's made the difference
the Yugoslavia has a communist regime
while Spain has a Catholic ideology and
that is apparently not acceptable to
those in control in our State Department
and I think it's time the American
people understood it then I understand
your senator that you believe that
American dollar spent abroad can be
spent very effectively in Spain I want
to thank you very much for being with us
tonight sir
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching Khurana scope was mr.
Donald I Rogers and mr. William Bradford
Huie our distinguished guests was the
honorable Owen Brewster United States
senator from Maine I went to the Museum
of the city of New York and I asked have
you got a picture of the New York of
1866 the reason of course was that in
1866 in New York the lawn gene wit nor
watch company opened its doors for
business they gave me this interesting
picture
they were sailing ships on the Hudson
and East rivers but there were no
bridges or subways no towns yet two
million people already made their homes
on Manhattan Island this was the same
when our company's travelers buy
horse-cars steam train and on horseback
first brought launching watches to find
jewelers throughout the land what's past
is tell you that has been ripped this
was the prelude to 85 years of
leadership in the art of fine
watchmaking a leadership symbolized by
ten world's fair grand prizes twenty
eight gold medal awards and highest
honors for accuracy from the world's
government observatories for beauty for
greater accuracy and for the promise of
a long and useful life these are the
finest lawn gene watches ever made lawn
gene the world's most honored watch the
premier product of the lawn gene with
noir watts company since eighteen sixty
six maker of watches of the highest
character
this is Frank Knight again reminding you
that the launch in Cronus cope is
brought to you three times weekly every
Monday Wednesday and Friday so won't you
join us every monday wednesday and
friday evening at this same time for the
long gene cross code a television
journal of the important issues of the
hour broadcast on behalf of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
on earth launching sold and service from
coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
display the emblem agency for long jean
wit nor watches
it's time for the launching chronicles a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which noir
watts company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the long
gene chroma scope mr. William Bradford
Huie editor of the american mercury and
mr. kenneth kramer executive editor of
Businessweek magazine our distinguished
guest for this evening is the honorable
Robert S curve United States senator
from Oklahoma the opinions expressed are
necessarily those of the speakers santé
currents a pleasure to have you this on
your return engagement on the karna
scope and it's seems particularly proper
to have you tonight because our audience
has been looking at a Republican
convention and I dare say that a great
many Americans have forgotten that there
are Democrats who are running for
president so tonight sir we'd like to
have some of your impressions of the
Republican convention now did you happen
to hear general Eisenhower's acceptance
speech no mr. Hewitt I didn't well why
not say well to tell you the truth I
felt he'd probably accept and mr. and I
hadn't had our dinners so we went to
Nate I knew if he didn't I'd hear about
it for long well now I suppose you did
follow the the convention very closely
yes I've been what are some of your
impressions of the Republican convention
circuit well the Republicans have again
demonstrated that they spend four years
making a record and then four months
running away from it they have again
refused to nominate a man who had
anything to do with the making of the
record that he's
don't have to run on they've selected
one who has had no part in making the
record and so far as I know no part in
in formulating the program for the
future you you don't think that the
Republicans have selected their their
strongest potential candidate well that
of course remains to be seen they have
they have at least disadvantage in the
man they've selected he doesn't have the
liability of any Republican record of
his own however he's going to have to
run on the record that they've made and
the program that they formulated now
nobody knows whether he's an able
campaigner or not they've got men who
are experienced campaigner do you feel
alone do you feel that he'll be able to
conduct as aggressive a campaign as
would have senator Taft for instance not
on the basis of the Republican program
and the Republican record no I do not do
you think Senator Taft would have been
able to conduct it a better campaign
well certainly senator Taft would have
had the advantage of at least knowing
something about what the record and the
program was and and and what his
position was and what he thought about
it well I was of the impression that the
general eisenhower has been telling the
American people what he believes for a
month now you mean you think that
there's still some doubts well he's been
indulging in glittering generalities
where he said anything on many questions
he's said I don't know I'll save this
for him he's down to the point now where
he's gonna have to get down to specifics
he's gonna find out that in this contest
that he's a part of now that people are
gonna expect and demand that he fish or
cut bait
what isn't the selection of INR as a
candidate going to change
the complexion of the issues of foreign
policy for example Ike is certainly not
an isolationist he's much closer to the
Democratic party line on foreign policy
isn't he are we going to make a campaign
issue out of foreign policy
well he'll have the opportunity to state
his position on foreign policy and and
it's well known that safar's he's
personally concerned he has supported
the the foreign policy in the main of
this administration but you must
remember this that he's not running
alone he's running as a part of a party
that have a slate of candidates and they
have candidates for the Congress as well
as for the presidency and should he win
and should they win and should he favor
the same foreign policy in the future
that he has indicated he favors in the
past he'd find himself in the very
unhappy position of being the captive of
of his own party who violently disagree
with him and who regardless of what he
thinks about it or says about it would
not let him have or carry out a foreign
policy similar to that one which the
Democratic administration has carried
out but he has been pretty clear in
saying what he believes is the foreign
policy of this country or what it should
be and he has been a participant in
activating the policy we have today oh
yeah but let me tell you he's been a
participant in carrying out the policy
of the majority party there now if he
becomes a part of the majority party
which are dedicated to a different
foreign policy you see Eisenhower has
been in the very fortunate position thus
far being in charge of whatever
situation he was a part of he was the
commander-in-chief of this or the chief
of staff of that or the president of
something else where his orders were
carried out now if he thinks he can give
that gang that he runs within calm
his orders and have them carry him out
he ought to get off in the cool and
quiet of some evening and have a
heart-to-heart talk with Harry and you
get the facts of life about how little
the executive sometimes has to do with
what Congress does it hasn't been true
that in in the last two Democratic
administrations we have we have seen the
chief executive be the molder of the
foreign policy it seems to me that's
getting to be the style these days well
but you see the chief executive had the
majority of his own party and a minority
of the opposition party supporting him
in that foreign policy now if he has a
great majority in his own party fighting
him in it then he's going to find that
he's under a handicap which he won't be
able to overcome any more than he's
going to be able to overcome the
handicap in this campaign of having to
carry the Republican banner March on the
Republican Republican record run on
their program so those were awful heavy
loads I don't believe I can carry him
senator to come back to the convention
the high points of it were there any
surprises for you for instance were you
surprised at general McArthur anything
in General MacArthur's speech oh no no I
I heard MacArthur's speech when he made
it the first time and then I I read
about it when he made it the second time
well now what about your colleague
senator Dirksen he's supposed to be the
great art of the Republican Party well I
enjoyed that I enjoyed what senator
Dirksen had the same he was just enough
of a realist and knew just enough about
what was happening and gonna happen that
that while he had the nation for his
audience he proceeded to read the
obituary of the
republican campaign for 1952 a senator
that i'm sure that our audiences
appreciated your criticism the
republican convention but after all you
now are facing the democratic one and
you were one of the three or four
leading candidates for the Democratic
nomination thank you sir thank you I
hope you'll get that message over to the
convention out of Chicago how many men
do you expect - how many names do you
expect to be placed before the
Democratic convention I'm sure there'll
be a minimum of ten candidates for
presidents in the Democratic convention
and what is the the approximate delegate
lineup at the moment sir who are the
leading candidates well I don't think
there's any doubt but what mr. Russell
and mr. Keefe offer are the two
frontrunners I would say that they'd
have in the neighborhood of 300 peace
and where do you stand sir there well
I'm hoping that I'll be no worse than
fourth I think I'll have a minimum of
150 on the first ballot and then more as
we go along yeah what is the Democratic
campaign platform going to be is it
going to be the repeat that is are going
to follow through on the Truman program
well of course nobody would be
presumptuous enough to say what the
platform committee would bring to the
convention or what the convention would
do with it in the main of course they'll
approve it but they have demonstrated in
the past that sometimes they make such
changes as they want on the floor of the
convention I'd say this the difference
between the Democratic Party in the
Republican Party is this they spend four
years making a record and then four
months running from it we spend four
years making a record and then four
years running on that record and on the
proposals that we have to improve it for
the following four years now sir what
our audience has just seen the big fight
over the seeding of southern delegations
and the Republican convention what will
be
similar fight in the Democratic
convention what will your big
inter-party battle intra-party battle be
over well there be a few contested
delegations or delegates not too many
and then we'll have honest men hearing
the contests and that man of equity and
justice deciding them and then our
convention will have that confidence in
their own committees and their own
judges that when the reports are brought
in it'll be a matter of routine to
accept them now senator as a final
question will you give our audience just
some idea of how you think the campaign
will develop from this point on and your
prediction as to what you think the
outcome of the campaign me well I think
that the campaign is going to go like
this mr. Eisenhower has a great decision
to make General Eisenhower pardon me
he's going to have to decide whether to
make a meet to campaign like Dewey and
Wilkie did embrace the democratic record
and program or pull a Taft and try to
blaze a new trail we do not know but
wherever he goes we'll meet him well
thank you very much for being with us
sick the editorial board for this
edition of the launching chroma scope
was mr. William Bradford Huie
and mr. Kenneth Cramer our distinguished
guests was the honorable Robert S curve
United States senator from Oklahoma
the the results of the 1951 competitive
trials at the famous Geneva Observatory
have just been published first prize for
the best watches in category C that's
wristwatches was won by a lone gene the
series prize for the first five watches
in this class was also won by a long
gene and all 12 of the long gene watches
entered won certificates now thus is
written another chapter in the long gene
record of success in Observatory
accuracy competition a record which
began in 1878 and one more reason why
throughout the world no other name on a
watch means so much as launching the
only watch in history to win 10 world's
fair grand prizes and twenty eight gold
medals and so many honors for accuracy
in fields of precise timing though every
launching watch is made to the single
lawn genes standard of excellence you
may buy and own or buy and proudly give
the long gene watch for as little as
seventy one fifty the gift watch of
great prestige is launching the world's
most honored watch premier product of
the long gene with nor watch company
since eighteen sixty six maker of
watches of the highest character
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time for the long gene Chronos code a
television journal of the important
issues of the are broadcast on behalf of
launching the world's most honored watch
and wit nor distinguished companion to
the world on a Longy
this is frank night reminding you that
long jean and wit nor watches are sold
and serviced from coast to coast by more
than four thousand leading jewelers who
proudly display this emblem agency for
launching with noir watches
it's time for the launching promise Co a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought so you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which nor
what's company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
David Ross may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching Khurana scope mr. William
Bradford Huie editor of the american
mercury and mr. James H R Cromwell
former United States minister to Canada
our distinguished guests for this
evening is the honorable Robert S curve
the United States senator from Oklahoma
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speakers senator curse
since you're our distinguished senator
from Oklahoma and a candidate for the
Democratic presidential nomination it's
a pleasure to have you here tonight sir
to discuss some of your views with our
audience now as a first question sir
where do you fit in the Democratic
firmament would you call yourself a new
dealer or Fair diva sir well you know
terms mean just what those who use them
intend that they mean I have supported
Roosevelt and in the main I have
supported Truman I call myself a liberal
Jeffersonian Democrat I see now would
you care to say whether you think of
yourself as being a Truman fare dealer
are you and are you in support of the of
what is known as Truman's fair deal that
he's now insisting on and has been
insisting on while he's been there well
I could tell you a number of things
which he is supposed to have included in
what has been termed the fair deal that
I don't agree with state medicine for
instance socialized medicine and
and some things which we might go into
but in the main I am a liberal Democrat
senator you have quite a record as the
governor of Oklahoma or having I believe
changed a state deficit into
considerable saving I believe that isn't
it true that when you were in office the
deficit was 45 million and when you left
what what was the situation I became
governor we were that much in debt in
Oklahoma when I left four years later
the last dollar of the dead had been
paid and we had a 40 million dollar
surplus well a senator of I read a very
interesting little squib in the paper
the other day to the effect that during
the war I think it was the year 1944
that our federal expenditures were and
taxes were around 44 billion dollars and
now in 52 with no war going on it's
we're going to spend I understand
between 80 and 90 billion dollars now as
a man whose record is so excellent in
trying to save money for the taxpayer
how would you handle a situation like
that were you president well as I as I
remember in 1944 the tax income was
under 50 billion dollars but the total
expenditure was around a hundred billion
dollars those were the years in which we
increased the national debt as you will
recall from about 40 billion to over 260
billion dollars now in the last five
years the combined income of the
government has exceeded its expenses
about eight billion dollars this year
will have a deficit of less however than
that amount next year a greater one but
we're paying as we go almost and as in
view of the fact that we passed the peak
of the defense spending next year
I think we can and will be back on a pay
as we go basis after the next fiscal
year to come back to the Democratic
Party senator Kerr as I understand it
there have been two movements in the
party itself there's been a movement
toward compromise and playing down the
differences within the party the
differences between the conservative and
the more liberal elements and then
lately even on the part of the president
there's been a sort of belligerent
attitude on the part of the New Deal
fair deal group now are you one of those
Truman belligerents that wants to drive
on toward more and more so-called social
games or do you believe that the time
has come for some compromise within the
Democratic Party
well all progress comes about through
compromise there are those who want to
go faster than others I must say to you
that I'm bout in the middle between the
two extremes in the Democratic Party mr.
Hewitt
you much the president was reported
yesterday is insisting that the big
issue in 1952 should be Truman ISM that
he'd like to see the the election
decided on the issue of Truman ISM and
that he expected to stomp the country in
the same manner that he did in 1948
well I'm sure that the president will
support the ticket but if he'd wanted to
make the issues he should have been the
candidate the issues will be made by the
Democratic convention in Chicago and the
new nominee then I take it that you are
you're you're none too anxious to R up
to make Truman ISM the the issue in 1952
well I'm neither anxious to make it in
order to keep it from it I recognize the
reality that the issue will be the
record and program of the Democratic
Party on the one hand in contrast to the
lack of either on the part of the
Republican Party how do you stand
senator on the so-called welfare state
do you believe in
in what is generally known as the
welfare state that they should state
should do all kinds of things for the
citizen the section says you know
unemployment insurance Social Security
you suggest Express the idea that you
did not approve of socialized medicine I
believe never in in any form or degree
but I am for the things that you have
talked about to my mind they don't of
themselves identify anything is a
welfare state
that's just another term that the
federal government belongs to the people
and they expect it to serve them and as
it does so constructively they will
support it and if it doesn't they'll
repudiate it but the greatest service it
can render the people is to improve the
opportunity of the average citizen to
build his own security but at the same
time recognize that the many reforms and
improvements in the way of social
progress and social security which we
have brought about are to the people's
benefit and the people aim to keep them
Oh senator I'm sure that our audience
would like a few questions on yourself
now I believe it is true that you're one
of those tremendously wealthy all men
from the southwest do you plead guilty
to that charge yeah my opponents have
always accused me of being a big rich
old man and then they go out and prove
it on me well you're the biggest and
richest man and that's running this time
for president I doubt that but I can
tell you briefly a little illustration
to that when I started running for
governor I thought the oil minute before
me and 2/3 of them were but they found
out I as a new dealer and it hurt me
but I'll tell you when the new dealers
found out I was an oilman it almost beat
me hi well now do you see anything in
Congress anything unusual about a big
rich Oklahoma oilman being such a fiery
supporter of
and Truman ISM or the New Deal social
legislation I've said this before and in
spite of the fact that its reputation I
want to say to you you should have seen
me in my family under Hoover we made
every dollar we've got under Truman and
Roosevelt and so far as I know most
everybody else did I'd venture to say
maybe that you did and I believe this
that those who have improved their
conditions under Roosevelt and Truman
should vote for a continuation of that
program and those who have suffered
might be justified in voting against it
there's one other question I believe you
have it's true that you are a Baptist
and a sunday-school teacher rather pious
man isn't that I'm a Baptist in a Sunday
school teacher I make no claim to being
class well since you have that
background sir how has all this
corruption and scandals and indication
of thievery down in Washington what have
you thought about that sir I'm just as
much against that as any other good
red-blooded American citizen can be and
ought to be do you think you could clean
it up I know I could uh are you speaking
generally sir do you as a citizen and as
an American are you concerned about the
fact that the federal government may be
gaining too much power over the
individual citizen of this country I'm
always concerned about any level of
government gaining too much power over
the individual citizen you're suspicious
of power always wherever it may be
economic power or governmental power do
you believe in these they're very large
expenditures for foreign aid I have
supported the foreign aid program thus
far provided believing that it was
buying us a greater amount of national
security than any other of the defense
expenditures we made just a words there
on your own campaign plans would you
could you tell our audience something
about what you expect to do between now
and the convention are you
entered in any other states I'm not
entered in any other state primary I'm
visiting every state that I can reach
I'm speaking to the Democratic
conventions and gatherings in those
states I am making myself as well-known
as I can to the delegates and the
alternates and to the people generally
how many delegates do you expect to have
committed to you by the time of the
convention well I would hope that I
would have more than I expect to have
and as a final question sir it's been
alleged and stated by people on both
sides that perhaps there's some danger
of both parties nominating the same man
this time now first do you think that
there is any likelihood of both parties
nominating the same individual for
president I think if there were any
possibility of it it would be a great
danger but I don't think there's any
possibility of it you're at any event
you wouldn't be in favor of any such
thing no sir any man that wants to carry
that Republican banner so far as I'm
concerned gonna have to carry it alone
well I'm sure that our audience very
much appreciate your views tonight sir
and thank you very much thank you
because it's opportunity the editorial
board for this edition of the launching
Crona scope was mr. William Bradford
Huie and mr. James H R Cromwell our
distinguished guest for this evening was
the Honorable Robert S Curl United
States senator from Oklahoma
do you have the problem of selecting a
gift of great prestige for someone
important to you for father on Father's
Day for instance well that problem is
most happily solved with launching the
world's most honored watch because of
the outstanding quality of the watch
itself and the cause of what the name
lawn jean stands for to the whole world
lawn Jean stands as the only watch in
history to win the highest of all Awards
38 times at World's Fairs and
international expositions including 10
grand prizes and twenty eight gold
medals long Jean the world's most
honored watch also stands for the watch
of first choice in sports aviation
science and other fields of precise
timing and lawn jeanne stands for the
watch to be classified first at the four
great government observatories
Washington Geneva cute Eddington and
norcia tell the gift of great prestige
for any occasion the father on Father's
Day or for your favorite graduate is
launching the world's most honored watch
and throughout the world no other name
on a watch means so much yet you may buy
and own or buy and proudly give a long
Jean watch for as little as seventy one
fifty launching the world's most honored
watch premiere product of the laun jean
wit nor watch company since eighteen
sixty six maker of watches of the
highest character
this is David Ross speaking for your
regular host Frank Knight inviting you
to join us every monday wednesday and
friday evening at the same time for the
long gene Khurana scope a television
journal of the important issues of the
hour broadcast on behalf of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honoured Longy sold and serviced from
coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
display this emblem agency for lawn jean
wit nor watches